how are you doing today sir
i'm good man i'm just looking at your
toys it's a matte painting it's not real
[Laughter]
i like having the stuff behind me
because no one wants to see my face
i think they'd rather see the toys while
i'm asking questions
is that ninja gotcha man yeah
by the way the other thing i have for
for the gotcha man stuff
i'm waiting for hollywood to do
something with this
you know it's uh you know like with
force five and brandeiser and guy king
these are great properties that have
never been mined
wasn't there there was quite a good cg
version in the early 2000s wasn't there
they did i think i saw a clip or a
trailer for it or something but
yeah but i mean i think that you know
there's been a lot of talk about kira or
there's been talk of robotech
um and these are you know these are cool
things that now technology i think
could allow you to tell these stories in
live action
yeah yeah definitely yeah i mean i've i
came to you through that battle of the
planet so it's slightly
slightly different no no i i watched
battle of the planets as well
we're on the same page so because i have
a few minutes with you uh
during the pandemic i ask everyone the
first few questions um
what tv series would you love to guest
write and direct
battlestar galactica thanks
by the way but i wouldn't want to
because i would rather watch it
but with them doing it than me doing it
sure i would love to see your battle
star galactica though
i do i do i guess i do guessed episode
of it i don't think i would want to want
the full control over it
because that's the fun of it is watching
that vision of it was brilliant you know
what movie or movies do you think you've
seen the most
uh blade runner is that one of these
things you've seen like 20 times or more
yeah endlessly have you seen
i'm assuming you've watched all the
various versions yeah
do you have a favorite um
the the directors cut
first version before they've started
tinkering with it with cg
got it is this one of these things where
when you're going to turn it on
do you purposely watch different
versions or will you just watch that
version again and again
i think i just watched that version
again and again to be honest but i don't
know maybe i'm watching the actual
the last because i'm watching streaming
now instead of watching the disc and
so i've got like so many i've got it on
all the different formats as well so
it's kind of
but now i just because i'm lazy i'll
watch the easiest version of it
like you i love blade runner um did you
are you a fan of 2049
i'm
not as much as the original got it
i i thought that denise did a really
good job with 2049 and deacon
cinematography
elevates it to it's just beautiful to
look at
yeah well i just got the storyboard book
and that just came out yesterday didn't
it i think which is
really interesting and been going
through all that i'll move on to
my last thing before we talk about your
movie um if you could get the financing
for anything tomorrow any project you
want to make
what would you make and why
tomorrow i don't know i mean i'm in the
mid i'm contracted so i can't do
anything tomorrow
so i'd have to do it in 20 20 23
right so i mean i i don't know
it would and that would really depend on
my mood at the time and what
it's tricky because i think having all
the money in the world
to do stuff makes you outside of the
flow
of culture and in a way
like all these movies that we like from
the past they were they were made under
a
financial and cultural imperative it
wasn't that they were just
people being given stashes of money that
they suddenly could do whatever they
wanted so
i think it would be dangerous to do that
you know in a way you want
you want to work within within the
culture and see what the shape of things
are before you would make something so
it's not as simple as just
you know getting a lot of cash and
bashing something out it's much more
reading what's around you and what what
could where there's a hole for something
to fit
completely um jumping into why i get to
talk to you today
uh really enjoyed this movie uh as usual
i had to turn away from the screen i
think three times
possibly four uh because of certain
visuals
uh that you depicted um i want to say
thank you for that
um so i'm curious uh
with this had to have been a challenging
movie to make due to trying to make it
during cove
and i'm curious how did the filming
process
during the pandemic impact possibly the
film you're
you're making in terms of being able to
pull off
a certain camera shot or being able to
go to a certain location can you sort of
talk about how covet impacted the actual
storytelling
um a lot of movies i've made have been
like uh pragmatic you know you work
from what you've got rather than
a blue sky situation where you go
you write your thing and then you try
and finance your dream
you know and you get it done it's
there's a different way of thinking you
know and so if you're working from
from um in genre
at low budget and and independent then
you kind of
and i've done this for all the movies
you know i start with a kind of
um a canvas that i know i can get rather
than
what you know that something that i can
hope i can get so
with this because of covid we realized
that
a film set indoors was probably not
going to work because of
it won't be safe for the crew at the
time when we filmed it and i was talking
to people about how
stuff indoors was being filmed and they
were having like these kind of
antiseptic foggers and wiping down all
the surfaces and
all this kind of stuff and that that
level of um
hygiene was not going to be something we
could do on on the budget that we were
working at so
that that was always the case it was
going to be outside
having said that the actual way the film
was shot
the pace it was shot at and the way i
interacted with the crew and the cast
didn't change there was nothing about
kobe that affected that
um we might have had 200 grams more
money
to spend on stuff if i hadn't had to
spend it on
hand sanitizer and masks and all that
kind of
stuff that you don't that doesn't get on
screen you know which is
is a slight a small dagger in my heart
but then the other thing is that
that's all there to make sure that you
know it would have been the worst thing
in the world if anyone had been sick
from making this film you know and we
were really really careful about how we
did it in that respect but in the end of
the day you know wearing masks and
and keeping distance a reasonable amount
of distance and keeping in a
in a bubble was not any kind of
aggravation you know it wasn't
it i would be a very you know go i'd get
no sympathy as a filmmaker trying to
make a case for how hard it was you know
what i mean
i i understand uh what with this story
and this film was this an idea that
you've been kicking around for a while
or can you sort of talk about the
genesis of the idea and why you wanted
to
tell this story um it would it
it's all brand new you know i think we
started writing it almost
exactly a year ago to the release date
you know so when it comes out in the
cinemas i would have
first got on the plastic piano and
started writing it so
which is pretty quick um and it was
mainly down to like i wanted to make
something
i figured that once the covid
once lockdown had happened that was
basically the end of that world that we
were we'd been in it
is over you know it's finished it's kind
of now we're in a new world
and any script that you had that was
about that old world and all the stuff
about that old world was kind of over
and dead
you know and everything had to be moving
forward from that position
so and i've always wanted to make stuff
that was that had that con
that contemporary edge but also that if
i'm making horror i want it to
be political and but also um
deal with real life um things around us
which is
you know something that
i'd gotten from reading george romero
interviews you know this is something
that horror does
it's a way it's a it's a a um
a kind of way of a prism for looking at
what's happening to us in the moment you
know and it is weird it's like people
talk about pandemic movies but this is
just a movie band now
this is actually this is it this is
happening you know
so it's kind of that so there was that
that side of it and that and
what i wanted the other things that had
kind of gone into it was that i wanted
to make another horror film i wanted to
go back
to the um to make something that was in
relationship to the other movies that
i've made like field in england
and kill list um i wanted to play in
that
that kind of pool again of of things and
um but i'd also kind of i was looking at
um i was looking at kind of my
relationship
as well to what folk horror was you know
and what how what had been
become since kill this because he wasn't
really even
even a sub genre at that point you know
or wasn't recognized as one you'd have
the three big movies but they weren't
like um uh blonde satan's claw and um
wicker man and uh but he was like
that you know that
i'd made i've made films that were seen
as folk films befo horror movies but
they hadn't
but i've made them kind of automatically
almost without knowing it was
more about a kind of my own
understanding of what
it was to be british rather than it was
a specific thing about
cinema you know what i mean but this
movie is more about that of trying to
understand
you know within it you have kind of a
position of kind of magic and
and folk and in the position of science
and then that these things
are merged over the top of each other
how much do you debate
what your opening shot is going to be
and what your closing shot is going to
be in a movie
do you find yourself like really
debating that
or are you in the writing process do you
sort of know it
um the opening shot
yeah sometimes but the ending is always
a
nightmare because the ending of the film
is
all important you know that's the thing
that's the takeaway usually
it's a weird thing of like a memory kind
of recedes
so you kind of that you're you remember
a film almost backwards and that's the
kind of thing that makes your judgment
on it so a bad
last 10 minutes can destroy a film
completely you know
and so the pressure really is on that
those those things to be as concise and
right as possible
um the beginning of a film is is it
well you've got basically i i feel
anyway that you have a certain amount of
time with the audience
where they give you the benefit of the
doubt anyway so you can be a bit more
loose
at the beginning of a film in a way that
that you just can't be at the end you
know
you wrote and directed but you also
edited this movie
and i'm curious um in the editing room
did you make any discoveries
that you you know weren't expecting in
the writing process and directing
um you know could you sort of talk about
because you know editing is the final
rewrite
yeah i mean i think that
it's more usually it's about compression
and it's like it's a bargain it's a
a kind of gamble that you take with the
script is that
you've got a certain amount of
information to pass to the audience
do they need to know it all and can you
want to have as little as that
information in the script um
but if you take too much of it out then
the film becomes harder and harder to
understand and then your audience
becomes smaller and smaller down to the
really incredibly intuitive people who
can just understand anything and then it
you know blossoms out from that to the
the whole audience you know so it's kind
of
that side of it is that's where the edit
is you know you kind of go oh
this seems too long and you can press it
and then go oh
man the film doesn't make any sense so
then it has to kind of expand back out
again and that's that argument of
how much of it can you chip away until
you get it to its leanest
state basically how long did you have a
much longer
cut of this movie um or was it very like
a lot of deleted scenes or was it very
similar to the final
length no it's exactly
there was was there a c a couple of
scenes went out of it but nothing
and certainly enough i mean i'm never a
fan of deleted scenes so i don't really
keep track of any of that stuff because
it's always it's like when you watch
your film it's really great and then
you go oh what else is on the disc you
know oh deleted scenes oh and you're
watching me go oh
i really enjoyed that film and now i've
watched a couple of scenes which are a
bit rubbish why did i do that to myself
i slightly ruined the experience you
know
and i think that's the it's almost like
you start being too greedy isn't it
you've eaten a cake and you want some
more cake and you'll take it from
wherever you can
get it and you know so i usually just i
don't think we've ever done deleted
scenes on any of the movies maybe
there's one on
there's some on sightseeing maybe but i
tend to go
i mean amy jump who um i work with a lot
she's saying
she always says never show how the
sausage is made you know destroy all the
evidence
i i see both sides of it because
sometimes i've seen deleted scenes that
are quite good but we're cut out for
whatever reason
and then i've seen terrible deleted
scenes that should never have been shown
you know so i mean the things that have
cut out of this are just
much more um
explanation you know and you kind of go
yeah well you know if there's a there's
a portion of the audience that love a
bit of explanation
and there's a portion of the audience
the hate explanation and then it's
driving that deal between those two
those two parts of the audience whether
you know who's who's going to win out
uh before i run out of time with you uh
i wanted to know
because i was a little bit surprised
when you signed on for the meg too
because it wasn't what i expected it was
like i'm like oh my god this is a
weird and wonderful choice um can you
sort of talk about
um what drew you to this material
i mean i just really love the meg
i do too this is a common thing when you
talk to people they go
i really love the meg and i go yes i did
too you know
it's a it's a it's a film that has a lot
of friends you know in it
and it was you know i usually just go
with my gut so something comes across
that
my you know from my agent and and i like
it then i just go for it so this came up
oh christ make two i'll do that that's
brilliant
uh can you talk a little bit about where
you are in the actual development
process
do you have a script are you getting
ready to film at a certain point
this story i've got yeah they've been
you know they've had us they've got a
script and
we've been doing storyboards for three
four months now so there's lots and lots
and lots of works been done
are you planning on filming this year i
don't know i don't know what the what
the ins and outs of the actual
the megage is at the moment got it can
you promise
that jason statham will punch a shark in
the face
punch a shark in the face i don't know
yeah maybe
i think wrestling with it and holding
its fins back maybe was
but yeah i think it you know they're big
they're big
um boots to fill you know the last film
was excellent so it's kind of
we don't want to um kind of uh
disappoint any meg fans that's for sure
uh i have to stop there and i'm just
going to say that i really am looking
forward to
uh your take on that material and um i
really enjoy it
in the earth and i you know obviously
i'm a big fan of your work and anything
i can do on collider to help support it
please thank you thank you so much